each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
I have this I'm tomislav urban from the
Texas Advanced Computing Center at the
University of Texas at Austin and I'm
going to be talking about the data
collection that we're putting together
for four next rad data as part of our
contribution to the terror grid effort
that tack is part of you've probably
heard a little bit about the target
already today and I'm sure many of you
are intimately familiar with it just to
give a little context of that project
these are the various member
institutions on it it's essentially a
large network high bandwidth network
meant to support scientific research
across across the country and initially
it had brought together essentially
computational engines and and sort of
traditional HBC resources with the
second phase of Terra grid in fact when
it became Terra grid and institutions
like pack joined the addition of a new
kind of resource was added that being
the concept of a data collection so in
this particular case tak contributed for
data collections what which is the the
next ride data the other three being
modus data satellite imagery lidar
elevation data and a CT scan of fossils
and geology which Julian will be talking
about tomorrow in fact so this
particular one is next fri data as i say
this was done in conjunction with the
center for research and water resources
which john used to work at before he
went to Duke and professor David
Maidment and in addition to just being a
data resource that sits out there for
people to hit is this is a related to
our efforts
under the the target science gateway
program to develop a poops to develop a
flood modeling gateway which will enable
hydrologist and others to go to a portal
essentially and create a storm event
over some area perhaps an urban area use
the lidar data from our other collection
integrate that with the with NEXRAD
precipitation data and run it through
the map to map flood modeling
application and so that should be coming
forth in the next couple of a couple of
years so I think we've already seen this
map or some version of this map today
this is the the distribution of doppler
Doppler next rad radar stations around
the around the country and this is where
the the data actually comes from
initially and it goes through a series
of products as it goes from the raw data
on the wire in that great artisan and
then sort of cascades through through a
series of products from level 1 to level
2 to level 3 and we are able to to get
this stream from from the NOAA port via
yoona data and collect that data then
you can take these sort of round round
disks representing each of the stations
and and patch them together into a kind
of a regular grid and convert
reflectivity because ultimately the
radar is just just hitting something in
the air moisture presumably or snow and
and and getting back a signal which then
has to be converted into an actual
estimate of precipitation which may or
may not be a one hundred percent
accurate obviously that that's for the
hydrologist I guess to determine but one
of the one of the things that you can do
is to take the reflective of data and
combine it with actual rain flow rate
engage point data and so that acts as a
sort of correction to the reflectivity
day that you're getting back and you can
say okay you know am I am i off base
here or is this a reasonable number so
the combination of this relativity data
with the stream gauge sorry with the
rain gauge data produces a product
called stage three stage 1 stage 2 and
stage ultimately stage 3 and this is
terribly confusing because you have this
level 3 product in a stage 3 product and
it seems that most stage people don't
know about the level people and vice
versa but at any rate this my
understanding of the stage 3 is that
that this is a precipitation product
which takes the ruffle pivot II and
correlates it with the the rain gauge
point data and and produces a a value
for precipitation in a grid cell and
these are available historically rather
the history of this data is available
from the national weather service for
these ten I believe they're actually a
couple of more there's guam and hawaii
and alaska as well but but for these uh
these uh so-called River forecast
centers and so we've been looking at the
Western Gulf forecast center for the
moment but ultimately the idea behind
this collection is to collect all of the
historical data for the country for all
of the time that it's available and in
fact to then integrate it in this second
to none yet with the real-time data
coming in that hopefully we can then
well I'll get to that later so yes as I
was like we have this this level two and
three real near real-time data coming in
as I said we're collecting that the file
formats are completely different from
the file formats that we're using in the
in the stage three data and so there's
definitely a problem around sort of
integrating these two data sources the
real time or the near real-time world
with these sort of corrected historical
world so
that's a whole constellation of
potential problems and opportunities
there so as I say this this collection
is focusing on the historic stage 3 data
for now and the the files are available
in as archives of one month's worth of
data for a particular River forecast
Center so it's just from from a purely a
logistical standpoint getting what a
hydrologist will typically want to do
according to my friends at the CR WR is
or at least may want to do in certain
scenarios is to examine a relatively
small spatial area for a extended and
extended period of time maybe on the
order of years and so to go in and
unpack these these files and expand them
and and then go it's just it's as the
logistical a problem it's inconvenient
at any rate the monthly files are then
unpacked into daily archives the daily
archives then contain the hourly files
themselves which are in a format called
X MRG I have to admit I don't actually
know what that stands for so these x MRG
files there they're binary there a
format there is specific to the neck
NEXRAD community they're approximately
300 gigabytes total for for for the pool
what we have so far so not I not a huge
amount of data but they are fairly
inconvenient for most folks in the
hydrology community community to to
decipher there's a whole lot of
documentation there's no api is out
there that sort of thing there are
issues with Indian s and and the the
files unfortunately also somewhat
inconsistent in terms of the format
themselves Oh change a file from 1989
will be slightly different in format
from a file in 2002 which is slightly
different again in 2004 and those
differences are different depending on
which
before casting are you talking about so
the matrix of possibilities here is
really quite extensive and and so that
they're all these hurdles kind of
standing in the way of simple and easy
use by hydrologists and others of this
of this data and don't forget me this is
the data that's already been sort of
digested it's already gone through that
yeah well the data as I say okay comes
from the National Weather Service I'm
not sure that that it's owned by them
per se but I mean it's it's certainly
not proprietary in any way I mean you
can get the just the National Weather
Service's heart John do you know
anything on that No so yeah that so yeah
but this matrix of possible file types
over over the 10-year period and and I
perhaps didn't mention that it is about
ten years depending on the river
forecast center so again the
availability of data is also
inconsistent across across the regions
somewhat so let me talk a little bit
about the grid that this is on because
it's a not it's not a standard grade
it's not kind of a lat long kind of
thing with a certain number of
kilometers for each one a grid cell up
in the north of the country might be a
little bit different even in area than
grid cell down below this blue thing
that this is I believe a accounting in
Iowa and the blue grid there is it shows
this H rap grid for which the which are
the cells about four kilometers on a
side that are measured for this stage
three data values are given in hundreds
of a millimeter and this is kind of an
interesting fact from the from our point
of view from a from a data storage point
of view and that is that on average
across time across regions about
ninety-five percent of these cells have
zero value in other words no
precipitation additionally as you saw in
the previous slide these these are sort
of circular areas and we have these
square river forecast Center's well
actually they're not
where they're sort of based on the water
sheds but we draw a square around them
to to get the data that comes back is
this square sort of drawn around that
River forecast Center and so we also
have a fair number of no data points as
well which we really don't need to store
I mean it's we can kind of assume zero
if if there's no data and the sorry if
there's no precipitation and and then
keep track of which cells would have
been no data it depending on the isle
region yes so well this isn't
necessarily a standard kind of an open
sort of standard it is it is fairly
understood and followed in this
community so this is kind of what one of
these things looks like it's a it's a
this unfortunate I don't have a map
under here one of the things that I
definitely want to move into is a better
integration with GIS systems fact that's
really the basis of our architecture
which I'll get to a little bit later but
this as you can't see is Texas here this
is the Gulf Coast down here New Mexico's
up up up in this corner and the colors
of course our show the the value of the
precipitation so as I mentioned before
the there are holes in this data there's
inconsistencies in it I'm hoping that we
can possibly go back to the raw data and
re generate some of the stage three data
to fill in the holes I just got an email
actually for my colleague who's working
on this and he's found even more
inconsistencies and just corrupt files
with bad headers and and and and that
sort of thing so so there's definitely
some cleanup which we talked about
earlier that needs to happen I think
that's one of the values of a collection
like this is that we can go through this
sort of bit of a mess and clean it up
and put it in a centralized location
that can then be retrieved in a
hopefully a fairly consistent manner the
as I mentioned before the file format
has been on state
ball across time and across the various
forecast center so again a clean up
definitely needed the nomenclature of
the the files themselves so when you
unpack these various archives and open
them up you can't really automate that
process to the extent that one would
like or at least it's more difficult
than want to like because they've
changed the the names of the files and
the names of the of the archives and so
forth so yeah bottom line it's it's
difficult to use hydrologists will often
extract this to ascii a John showed an
example of that kind of thing where you
you you end up with this this ASCII kind
of output data ingestion is definitely
complex and quite laborious and I think
that's really the opportunity for for
for this data collection we can simplify
the retrieval through web applications
and web services in particular the other
advantage here is that you don't have
this kind of artificial separation
between months hours and River forecast
centers I mean if you want to get a
chunk of data that spans multiple files
multiple archives it's all there it's
all in database if you want to get some
data that spans multiple river forecast
Center's again if there is no need to go
to multiple sources and unpack all this
stuff it's all in the database and then
finally I we have several ideas in terms
of the kinds of formats that we want to
allow people to retrieve the data in
I'll get to that a bit later so this is
kind of our setup here we have about 2
terabytes of SATA disk a sequel server
this is this is still the old sequel
server the or the current sequel server
because we have our caisse de sitting on
top of it and this is the Azeri spatial
data extensions layer and while we
aren't using this this gif server yet
we certainly want to look at making some
of those geoprocessing funk that some of
that geoprocessing functionality
available as part of this web
application and/or service and then web
server on top the I'll talk a little bit
about the schema that we're using this
is actually a somewhat standard schema
John mentioned this earlier we're using
arc hydro which was developed at CR WR
in conjunction with ESRI the GIS folks
and this is really an extension to their
standard sort of GIS data schema which
includes things like hydrogue junction
help me out here John hydro point hydro
this and that and so what well I steal
thunder from a later slide but so that
there is at least in the GIS context
some standard that we are subscribed to
here so theoretically this thing
including the last ten years of data
would have roughly 50 billion data
points of those because the ninety-five
percent rule about 500 million contain
actual precipitation data the the no
data a problem can be solved to some
extent by keeping track of the masks of
no data because those are consistent i
mean the radars aren't moving around or
anything so you just you have to keep
track of it once for every River
forecast Center and then make note of
the date that the user is requesting and
then simply replicate that mask across
for every time step so that's how we can
we can make the problem a lot smaller so
this is this is a slide that that i got
from from david madman as well and it
just expresses this this this notion
that there needs to be flexibility in
terms of of how the data can be
retrieved so at the moment we only have
one variable right and that's that's
precipitation but you can imagine water
quality and
and and evaporation and various other
variables being available their
biodiversity all sorts of things but but
the idea is that when these things are
in files you're sort of limited to this
kind of a query you say give me an give
me the entire country or give me a river
forecast center for a given hour or a
given month and it really makes it very
difficult to do this kind of a query
which is give me the San Antonio River
Basin for the last 10 years over the
last two years or whatever and and so
one of the the value what the value we
hope that the database can bring to this
data collection is to allow both of
these kinds of queries and as I say at
the bottom here hopefully not this one
you know where there then give me the
entire country for the last 10 years
because that's that's going to bog
things down but at any rate that's
that's one of the power the power of the
database that we can hopefully bring to
this this collection okay
so in terms of how people would I the
interfaces that people would use to
access this collection of course web
services is one in fact I sort of see
that as the main one we know for a fact
that that our colleagues that crw are
are interested in using it in this way
they usually use Visual Basic in in in
their development and they visual
basic.net and they want to be able to
take this this class definition drop it
into their application into their client
application and simply invoke some
simple calls to the web service and
retrieve an actual object that they can
then manipulate on on there and that may
not be the standard mode for for others
I mean and I'll talk about that as well
certainly retrieving files and even
ASCII text is is a is it as an
alternative but this is kind of a nice
elegant sort of solution because it
gives it gives the client users some
some power in terms of the structure of
the the object but the typical query
would be a lat longitude box actually
should have two of those sorry about
that sort of a two points there I start
time and an end time and then the type
of format they want the thing returned
in and I'll go over those in a bit or
they could do it by a trap cell and then
an XY extent and return format and then
once we get the GIS piece in there they
could actually go in there and pick
irregular basins or watersheds and then
get only the cells that are associated
with that particular irregular shape so
as I'm really glad that John had that
slide earlier about the kinds of
software that hydrologists use windows
really is the dominant the dominant
platform in that world certainly there
there there is Lennox and use and it
especially some of the the processing
that I talk about her like gem pack for
example only runs on linux so depending
on the
the type of abuser that you are the
there could be both but Windows is
certainly as a good market share in that
domain as does the s3 GIS software as I
mentioned before would like the
opportunity entire objects the current
Visual Studio web service doesn't
support multi-dimensional arrays so
that's a bit of an issue we've had to
resort to array of arrays which is
certainly doable but it's a little bit
inconvenient and awkward in terms of the
programming opened app is something
we're looking at as well for
multi-dimensional data I'll talk about
it a little bit in the next slide but
this this each of these hour-long data
points or time steps has metadata
associated with it of course when it was
collected that that's obviously
necessary but then also the name of the
operator the platform it was generated
on the maximum value across that our in
other words the maximum precipitation
these kinds of things so and do we need
to give that with each slice each time
step if you're doing it for ten years
that sets a fair amount of overhead and
then the collection of of a trap cells
with value meaning for example in the
case of returning a basin which is
irregular associating an array with each
cell in that in that basin is also an
option so these this kind of a
description of or diagram of those three
those three possibilities you can kind
of have a collection of time steps each
with its own metadata and its own value
array you had a little bit a little bit
heavy in terms of the amount of metadata
that you're returning or you can have
metadata for the entire the entire query
and then a big three-dimensional chunk
that returns the or if it's multi
variable then it would be four or five
six dimensional and we can't do that in
the current web services and there are
concerns also there in terms of the size
of that though ultimately it's all the
same data and then we can have the
individual
cells with each with an array of values
associated with that and then metadata
in terms of the location of the cell and
and of course the time so then on the
web application side this is the sort of
thing we envision doing go grab a square
same thing essentially this could even
use the web service on the back end and
and then the the alternative would be to
select irregular basins you just click
on them you get that basin and then and
then collect select as many as you want
and then and retrieve them so the okay
so let's talk a little bit about these
various formats the thing that we were
actually asked to start with was was a
ski so this is really just a text file
with a little header of metadata and
then a big long list of H raft cell IDs
so it's a six-digit identifier can start
with a0 identifying the the a trap cell
and then and then of course the value
the pro here is that it's it's actually
commonly used and it's it's simple for
users to deal with they don't have to
know how to read binary files and that
sort of thing of course it's quite
inefficient as well as I talked about
before netobjects who can hand and those
those around obviously not particularly
handy for people who are or aren't
programming on on net or who can't get
the client code for whatever reason or
don't want to we can we can take
repackage essentially the data that came
in into the appropriate shape and return
in X MRG file right back justin lee in
the correct with the correct data that
they want and and the netcdf is another
that's an open standard that we can we
can use it's actually fairly similar to
the X MRG format in that you have a
header and then blocks of data and then
for each time step you'd have an
additional block and then finally for
the GIS users what would actually seems
to be the most convenient is
actual geodatabase so we would actually
return an MB MDB you know access
database file with the data and also
data about the the various cells so each
cell would be an object or a record in
that in that database with its unique
identifier and this can just plug
directly into a GIS model so that's the
convenient thing there in fact that's
probably where we're going next just
because that's what our users are asking
for so future plans on this first of all
we have to get all the data in there
right now as I mentioned we're only
dealing with one River forecast Center
the Western Gulf we need to load in the
rest of that cleanup hopefully fill in
some of the holes that we have and and
get that going but then after that we'd
like to add variables so that third
dimension that I showed earlier yeah
yeah but that's that's a well it's so
again in the terror grade context where
you have all this bandwidth to use and
you want to be able to the one of the
projects this is also so just associated
with which I didn't actually mention is
a project that Microsoft is sponsoring
to look at using relational databases in
a scientific context and one of the
things that we would definitely want to
look at in the context of that project
is running sequel server on a cluster
and having direct i/o from the various
nodes in the cluster to a compute node
for example or so yes not specifically
in terms of this collection but in the
in the broader context of things yes we
are looking at at essentially parallel
IO from database clusters okay so yeah
so some of the the additional data gauge
point data so rain rain gauges and
stream gages water quality and then
another thing that this of quite a bit
of interest is integrating this data
with other collections that are
available via Web Services in a seamless
sort of manner so you can come here make
a request for eight variables we might
provide one or two or three of those and
then the service would go out and and
aggregate the data from six other web
services and provided in some hopefully
cohesive manner and then follow as I as
I said at the beginning we'd like to
integrate the real-time data feeds and
they're there already some applications
that we've identified in terms of of
where this can be an input to another
application sitting on top of it and
extending the GIS integration
functionality just wanted to run real
quick little demo of an application we
build this is actually sort of our is a
desktop application that we built as our
central location for inputting the data
for ingesting the data and and for kind
of taking it out again so normally I
would be doing this from a database
since I don't
have sequel server on this laptop I'm
going to go to two files and I'm
grabbing a number of ours is about 24
hours worth of data just so you can see
a little bit of how this this particular
thing this is from June in the Western
Gulf so that same area from the Gulf of
Mexico up through through you MEK ya to
New Mexico so you can see here it's nice
little meteorology thing and that's it
any questions thank you